how did you become acquainted with our
world and our podcast is it are you a
listener of the podcast well I guess I
started by watching your videos on
YouTube back when I was maybe in high
school I don't remember how I came
across the first Conan video I ever saw
but right yeah they're so they're so I
mean they're so ubiquitous and so a part
of everyone's life it's kind of like
saying what's the first no it's like
it's like saying when was the first time
you caught a ball or caught the common
cold thank you yeah well okay you son of
a uh yeah it's like this life free
Conan and post Conan but I don't
remember the shift yes who remembers
their first bout of diarrhea no one but
you move on in life so uh you nailed it
you got there with your helpful friend
well so tell us you started listening to
you started watching the videos and then
you started listening to the podcast
yeah so I think your podcasts started
coming out just when I was
um maybe about to do my Master's Degree
so um yeah they came at a great time
because
um I was in another country Alone
um
struggling with sort of loneliness a
little bit and um they they really kept
me company uh got me through my M.A and
um you know you've been like my Spotify
top listen for the past every single
year since since you've put the podcast
out that's nice thank you very much
that's that's really sweet we're all
very honored that you would listen to
our uh foolishness and I understand that
we've been some help to you in your
romantic life is that true oh yeah yes
that's right um I somehow bonded with my
boyfriend over your show as well and and
yeah we'd like watch Clips or send Clips
to each other and then just sort of
discuss how Conan is like PP comedy oh
that's incredible hey I like this guy a
lot uh who is what's this guy's name uh
his name is Graf so so
um in Thailand people have nicknames
that don't really have anything to do
with their personality you might know
that but
um so his nickname is just graph and
that's the nickname he was given at
Birth so you know it's not like he's a
mathematical Wizard or anything but he
could have been named anything people's
nicknames are often just inanimate
objects yeah do you have a nickname yeah
what's your nickname I'm one of the
weird Thai people who don't have a
nickname oh okay we should give her one
yeah yeah yeah podcast yeah podcasts or
VCR remote uh huh no I think podcast
yeah well because it seems like it's
it's got some meaning behind it we'll
find you a good nickname but for now
your podcast okay
um I'll accept that yeah well you really
have no choice we I mean this is what we
do that's right he's telling the truth
podcast yeah you just have to understand
podcasts that when you and graph yeah uh
met uh it was foreordained uh that's
right so what happened did you
were you in a cafe and you heard this
handsome gentleman across the cafe
chuckling
and you said excuse me sir
what is you chuckling at and he said oh
that that rascally Conan and then you
said why I I enjoy Conan as well and
then Hearts came out of your heads is
that is version of fan fiction is this
yeah is this what happened his own
erotic picture yeah
so what uh is
if you knew each other
let's say 11 12 we were we were school
friends and um we'd always sort of been
close-ish but then
um yeah we started you know sort of
talking
um towards the end of like high school
and
um and I don't I don't know how you came
up I think I think maybe he even sent me
the first video and sort of got me on to
you or something yeah and oh yeah the
rest is just sort of History really
that's nice yeah how long have you two
been together now
um it's going to be 10 years next month
wow that's been a while yeah it's been a
while are you getting pressure from your
family are they saying what's happening
uh yeah my mom just keeps saying you
know I want a grandchild I want a
grandchild all the time so uh that's fun
but
um every time
um every time anybody we know says you
know when when are you gonna get married
when you're gonna have kids blah blah
and we'll be like if you just give us
the money to like have a wedding and the
money to like raise a child for
until they go off to college then yeah
just do that and Conan you have a lot of
money yeah pay for it well I did first
of all I'd love to and I I did have a
lot of money uh some bad Investments
were made uh and I apologize I thought
Neko Wafers were coming back those yeah
and uh I went all in I thought there'd
be a huge Resurgence during kovid of a
very untasty uh wafer good shock though
uh yeah from the 1902 and so I went all
in built a factory anyway
um I would like of course I would love
if you two wanted to be together uh you
know uh and and and and become married
someday I feel like I should be there
because I was let's be fair I was one of
the reasons that you two came together
honestly yeah would you officiate for us
yes I would
yeah I've done it before I've I've
married people before I have uh I'm
registered online as a minister with uh
the the Church of the Holy get groovy
and uh
um I think it expired all I think all I
have to do is press control alt three
and I'm re-entering again that easy I
don't know can you do it in Thailand I
think I haven't looked into the laws in
Thailand but I'm 100 certain I can okay
I mean this this is binding oh yeah yes
yeah audio and video proof so yeah yeah